andalist of Uncle joins us now from
Jerusalem morning Alistair tensions
bubbling over there
yeah yet another day of violence here
after the attack last night this is East
Jerusalem uh it's the District of silwan
which is a Palestinian District but
there are a number of Israelis who who
live here as well and so it is often a
very very tense neighborhood in
Jerusalem it's very close to the center
the Alexa mosque with the third most
holy site in the Islamic faith and the
Western Wall the most holy side in
Judaism are three or four hundred meters
away so it is very Central Jerusalem the
attack happened at 10 42 Israeli police
say so just around 8 45 UK time I'll
just read you a bit of their latest
statements they say that the terrorist
was shot by two passes by carrying
licensed weapons now they've revealed
that the identity of the attacker they
say he was neutralized incidentally
which normally is language to say that
he was shot dead but we understand that
he might still be alive
um he's a 13 year old a resident of East
Jerusalem the police have recovered the
gun that he used in the attack there's a
very heavy police presence here still as
you would expect uh and Intelligence
Officers going over the scene a number
of journalists as well and of course a
lot of the residents are here watching
what is going on because things are
incredibly tense in the city at the
moment particularly after a number of
days of violence in the west bank and
then that terrorist attack last night in
East Jerusalem that killed seven
Israelis